hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to this second video on the
order flows Delta surge now you know the
Delta surge is a free indicator that we
give away on our website order flows
calm and it works on ninjatrader 8 it
doesn't work on TLS it doesn't work on
tradestation I use ninja trader 8 and
that's why it was programmed for ninja
trader 8 so it could be downloaded
simply by going to order flows calm
slash Delta surge HTML at the bottom of
the page you will have to enter your
name and email address to get access to
the download now before I begin you know
a brief disclaimer you know please
understand that trading involves risk
and only risk Apple should be used for
trading so you know the Delta search the
reason I released it you know for free
is because you know a lot of people say
hey Mike you know I'm interested in
trading with the order flow but you know
I don't know where to start and yeah in
order flow there's a lot of different
data points so to speak right Delta you
got pointed control Delta runs on the
bottom you have point of control you
have imbalances and the Delta surge is
actually one of the ways that when I I
first started using order flow you know
way back when was it it helped me
understand you know when buying or
selling in terms of you know the
aggressive buyers or the aggressive
sellers when they're you know sort of
waking up and getting stronger and you
know for for example here right this is
wheat right I used to trade a lot of
commodities that's how I end up getting
my job at JPMorgan is because I was a
commodity trader I spent you know many
years at Cargill which is a big
commodity trading company I spent years
at ETF man and you know if you've ever
traded commodities you know things like
wheat or corn you know beans as beans
can move pretty good but you know some
of the other commodities like you know
palm oil and bean oil and soy meal
you'll understand what I'm talking about
on sideways moving markets so for
example wheats all right we would you
know wheat is a market it oftentimes
goes sideways
it makes them
go sideways makes a move and what I
would be looking for in the order flow
is clues on okay well which way are we
going to do it we're just gonna keep
going sideways or we gonna move lower
we're gonna turn around go higher and I
would look at the Delta and look for
clues there so you know if you
understand what Delta is it's the net
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers aggressive buyers are
those that buy at the market aggressive
sellers are those that sell at the
market you know when I say at the market
you know they could be hitting the bid
they could be sweeping through the book
basically they're coming in there being
the aggressor in the market so if the
Delta is negative right the final Delta
here you can see the top line Delta
minus 12 it tells me sellers are in
control barely it's only minus 12
there's only 12 more aggressive sellers
than aggressive buyers the next bars -75
tells me in this bar there were 75 more
aggressive sellers than aggressive
buyers minus 164 tell me there's 164
more aggressive sellers then aggressive
buyers so I know over these basically
these four bars
it went from aggressive buyers to
aggressive sellers more aggressive
sellers more aggressive sellers so I
would know that aggressive sellers are
you know over this period here
aggressive sellers are in control okay
now how would I use that is you know if
I would be looking for weak points in
the market okay in this case for sells
I'd be looking for a weak points in the
market if it was a delta surge by I'd be
looking for signs of strength and you
can see here right right here at the low
so I'll be looking for you know more
selling coming in you know at these lows
and so I can imagine right the initial
low here is what five forty one and
three-quarters market keeps going and
selling off selling off selling off five
forty one and three quarters you see
here's another Delta surge coming in
another Delta surge coming in all the
way down to the lows of the day down
here at 5:29 so this market dropped you
know from up here what it was trading
you know 541 and a half
down to five down you know down to new
lows on the close of the day all right
so is it nice 10-cent drop in wheat now
again you know what was the for me what
was the early sign that this market was
gonna sell off was the Delta surge the
aggressive selling coming in pausing
more aggressive selling coming in
pausing alright then I know that there's
more aggressive selling going on than
aggressive buying so you know for at the
lows the day aggressive selling coming
in it's got a it's got more opportunity
to go lower
unless there's obviously gonna be signs
of aggressive mind coming in now it's a
little bit different when you're looking
at markets that aren't necessarily
driven by supply and demand the way
commodity markets are right the
commodity markets you know are really
more tied down to supply and demand then
say equity markets okay so like for
example the e-mini x' you know there's a
lot of speculative money going on in
there there's a lot of money that goes
into those markets that never see
commodities and you know there's I don't
say it's it's not based on supply and
demand but it's it's more based on
return on the money right then then
necessarily trading in supply and demand
yeah you're not gonna eat your stock
certificates but you know things like
wheat go to delivery physical delivery
you know we're the ultimately producers
make food out of it so you know there's
sort of a different dynamic that goes on
with things like equities as as opposed
to commodities now you know I sent the
email out yesterday and you know people
are saying I made a mistake I
accidentally put the gold chart in there
twice I supposed to do a emini chart and
a gold chart but for some reason I
accidentally copy pasted posted both the
gold chart as both of them but anyway I
did get a lot of questions about how
does it look on the micro charts right
the micro minis or the micro Nasdaq so
let's just take a look okay I'm just
gonna this is the Delta search on the
micro emini the mes contract okay I'm
just gonna go back this is what day is
this here this is xx which is what
Monday night this Monday night or Sunday
night let me just see
well yeah starting on the 20th okay so
at 5:00 p.m. so you can see there's some
nice little cells coming in here okay
nice little cells now again the Delta
surge is not a tool that's supposed to
pick every single mark a turning point
based on the order flow it's looking for
expansion either to the strong side or
to the weak side whether it's aggressive
buyers or aggressive sellers coming into
the market and you know you can see here
right this is just in the evening
session all right here's a nice little
cell here's a nice little cell here this
one you know I sort of came back before
it dropped off this one it dropped off
and then you know stopped Jonathan
here's a nice little cell here there's a
nice little cell here a nice little cell
here okay so just go back you know this
is on now the 21st in the morning early
morning going into the main session here
you know there was nothing during this
period okay fine but then you get the
bye you got the cell there you got a
late bye
here's a cell did come up a bit and then
you got a nice bye here this body didn't
work out there was a nice cell up here
now you know the difference with trading
commodities and trading markets you know
like equity markets for me is I'm not
you know how to put it I'm not afraid to
sell new highs or new lows in
commodities because I know that
underlying what's that force underlying
is really supply and demand I'm a little
bit hesitant to buy new highs or sell
new lows in equities just because it
sort of the market makeup is a bit
different so honestly I would prefer to
be taking cells up near heís not buys
near highs I'd be for preferred
take byes sort of near swing lows in the
equities that's that's me
that's how I trade in regards to
equities you know there's uh again these
are coming in near the low of the day
again you know it's up to you there's
still capacity for the market to go
lower but how much lower can it go
alright I prefer to take a signal like
this you know coming off a swing high
but this is the mes you know again if
you could short this going into the lows
but I think the better trade is to get
long coming up off the lows just like
here the I think this is a better trait
to take then you know like this or this
you know after you just had a nice rally
but you know to each their own
so let's take a look at Nasdaq you know
not everybody's gonna trade the way I
trade and I'm not gonna trade the way
you trade you know it's about finding
your own trading style that resonates
with you
okay you should nice little cells here
this was on the 20th coin it's a 21st
again I don't want to go into all these
things that you want to show you you
know how it performs on these different
micro contracts because you get a lot of
people asking how does it look on the
micro contracts now again you know the
settings you can change the settings
I'll just talk about that really quick
in a minute so that's that okay so you
can see here right the settings the ones
are you really going to be concerned
with is this bar minimum bar D Delta
difference bar C minimum Delta
differences default is set to 25 and 25
you could change it say it's in
percentage I have to really
open this up so you can see here see in
percent so you know you could even use
you know no you know 1% okay say you
want just an incremental change sort of
the the smallest change that you can get
you set it to one not that it's going to
make that big a difference but you know
if you set it to say one it's by gonna
give you a few more signals the I prefer
twenty five and fifty that's me but
again you got to decide on what the
increase in Delta that you want to be
you see it's it's not giving that many
more signals but it's giving a few more
signals you know and again you know with
more signals you gotta realize there's
gonna be more trades you know some
people like to have a lot of trades so I
suggest you set it to the minimum so you
know again yeah anyway it's a free
indicator go to order flows calm / Delta
surge that HTML you don't have to send
me your machine ID nothing you just you
just install it as you would any other
ninja script add-on and you know just
make sure you got tick replay enabled
and you know go from there
right and just make sure you know if if
you pull up a chart okay for example all
you know some people scale their charge
differently you know if your chart is
you know a very big chart like this
right and you don't see anything you
know scroll to the left look look in the
past I see yeah I just have it scrunched
up so you can see things a lot clearer
but you see you got some nice little
moves here and here you know again some
nice moves and this is in the you know
if you trade around the clock you can
see there's opportunities in the evening
session as well as well as the day
session so anyway guys I'll end it there
again go to the website you can see here
this is the URL order flows calm slash
the Delta surge it downloaded it before
please switch to the new version
which is this one this is version 3.0
0.0 0.2 I believe but anyway I've
updated the website last week so if
you've downloaded it in the last week
you have the correct version if you
download it in last year
please read please go back and get the
new version so thanks everyone have a
great day